in their match today and he can still  strike back and the rain is starting  again in oslo we can hear him pouring on  the roof and moves are coming out in  magnus crossing against initial gear  it is a huge move you know and that is a  very thematic uh sacrifice actually  jumping in with the knight to the center  of the board just to open up lines to  attack the black king in the middle  and uh well  i thought the black king was safe as  houses but uh it's not now yeah we must  add here that this sacrifice the  computer hates it it's very typical um  wow we can hear thunder above us it's  like oh the god of thunder has arrived  here annoying that's great timing yeah  he slams that move on the board and you  get the lightning  as  and let's jump in because this knight  sacrifices your vanco mentions it's very  thematic it's very typical in this  opening the sicilian the whole idea is  to open up